contrôle continu grand oral voilà à quoi
ressemble le bac en 2022 mais une seule
épreuve résiste à tous ces changements
la philosophie flavie en filière
technologique est la première à rendre
sa copie moi j'avais fini je voyais pas
pourquoi je resterais plus longtemps
donc je suis je suis parti je vise la
moyenne puisque philo c'est pas trop mon
truc au bout de deux heures d'épreuve la
majorité des élèves commencent déjà à
sortir bien inspirés par les sujets j'ai
choisi revient-il à l'état de décider ce
qui est juste donc je pense avoir bien
réussi j'essaie de parler de ce qu'il
fallait avec l'état ce qui se passe
actuellement avec les confinements en
france avec locaux vides j'ai réussi à
akalé des philosophes rousseau le jean
jacques et puis c'est léger tout
simplement c'est facile
d'autres au contraire ne cachent pas
leurs angoisses
j'ai eu l'impression d'avoir des sujets
que j'ai jamais travaillé en cours du
coup c'est ça a été un peu ça ma
difficulté mais bon j'ai fait avec eux
les connaissances que j'avais je pense
que les épreuves de spécialités se sont
mieux passées clash et le pr depuis sa
réforme en 2019 la note du baccalauréat
repose à 40% sur du contrôle continu et
1 60% sur les épreuves finales la
philosophie reste quand même un pivot
du baccalauréat et même dans le cadre de
cette réforme c'est là où on commence à
tracer sa voie professionnelle
expérimentée l'an dernier la correction
des copies de façon dématérialisée va
être généralisé pour toutes les épreuves
quant aux résultats ils seront dévoilés
le 5 juillet prochain